ردًا على ما رأيناه اليوم
، أصدر وزير الخارجية الإسرائيلي
بيانًا وأريد فقط أن
أقرأ جزءًا منه اقتباسًا أن إسرائيل
ملتزمة بحرية العبادة للناس من جميع
الأديان في القدس وهدفنا هو
تمكين الصلاة السلمية من أجل  المؤمنون
خلال عطلة رمضان ، فإن أعمال الشغب
كما يشيرون إليها صباح اليوم على
جبل المعبد غير مقبولة وتتعارض
مع روح الأديان التي
نؤمن بها والتقارير التي تشير إلى
قيام الشباب الفلسطيني بإطلاق
الألعاب النارية ورشق الحجارة ، مما
أجبر قوات الأمن على الرد عليها.
القنابل الصاعقة والرصاص المطاطي ردك
كما هو معتاد حسب الإسرائيليين
الفلسطينيين هم المعتدون دائما
وحتى عندما
يكونون الضحية هم الذين يلامون
أه أنا كنت في المسجد بعد
الهجوم الإسرائيلي فكان هناك الكثير
من الصلوات  كان هناك آلاف
الأشخاص
لم يهاجم أحد الجيش الإسرائيلي ، كان
الجيش الإسرائيلي هو الذي استمر في إطلاق النار
على الناس لذلك  في رأيي لا يوجد أي
مبرر لذلك دعني أخبرك
أنه يتحدث عن حرية
الوحي ، لقد ابتعدت عن
الحديث المتبادل للمسجد ثلاث مرات
قبل أن أتمكن من الدخول دون
علمهم قالوا لي إنني ممنوع
من دخول المسجد.  على الرغم من أنني طبيبة ، أبلغ من
العمر 68 عامًا وأنني
ولدت في القدس ، أعني أن هذا مثال
على منع 90 فلسطينيًا من
الوصول إلى المسجد اليوم ، كان هناك
المئات من نقاط التفتيش لمنعهم
وأكثر من ذلك
كان المصلين المسالمين  هاجموا بطريقة عدوانية شريرة
وغير مقبولة ،
هذا يجب إدانته ودعني
أخبرك بصراحة أن الفلسطينيين
غاضبون للغاية عندما يرون هذه
المعايير المزدوجة في المجتمع الدولي ،
تتلقى روسيا أكثر من
6000 فعل عقابي وعقوبات وليست
عقوبة واحدة ضد
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي ونظام الفصل العنصري